Hello there!
Folks, my next guest tonight
has been a Roman Catholic
priest for 30 years.
Today, he is the author
of this book right here,
"Father Orsini's Pasta Perfecta."
(audience laughs)
Please welcome the
self-described Pope of Pasta,
Father Joseph Orsini.
(audience cheers)
How are you?
Good to see you, Father.
Thank you.
Let me just ask you very quickly,
I was looking at the
cover of your book today,
can we show this please?
You made a pope's hat
out of pasta.
Yes.
Have you heard from
the Vatican about this?
No, but I wish I would.
(Conan laughs)
I don't think you wanna bring it
to their attention.
No, no, no.
If it were banned, we would
sell a million copies.
Oh!
So what do you care?
You just want the dough.
Exactly.
You sicken me.
(Father Joseph laughs)
You and your kind sicken me, Father.
(audience laughs)
You sicken me.
Well, pasta's made out of dough.
[Both] Ah!
If you ever make a pun again on my show...
(Father Joseph laughs)
All right now, what are
we gonna cook today?
What are we making here?
The first thing we'd like to
do is get the pasta ready,
could you take the cover off of that pot?
I don't think I can do that, no.
Yeah, I can do that, sure.
Sure you can.
Okay, there we go.
All right.
And just empty the pasta in there.
(chuckles) Okay.
Glad we had you come on TV
to show me how to do this.
(Father Joseph laughs)
There we go, how's that?
(audience laughs)
Terrific.
You really don't know how
to cook, do you?
No, I don't know
how to cook at all.
(Father Joseph laughs)
All right, so what are we making here?
What's the name of this dish?
Okay, this is linguine (speaks Italian).
It's named after the goddess Aphrodite.
Who was the goddess of love.
And this was more or less invented
in the region of Campania,
which is near Naples.
Yes, yes.
It was made originally because,
women who found their
husbands a little bit weary
to perform the husbandly duties.
They would
Oh, Father!
Oh, yes.
What are you talking about?
We're talking about real life.
Yeah, so this makes you high.
This makes you ready for action.
It helps, it helps.
You're basically cooking an aphrodisiac.
Exactly, well, aphrodite,
aphrodisiac, sure.
Okay, alright.
All right.
I don't think you should be doing this,
but anyway go ahead.
(Father Joseph laughs)
This is really
But you eat this stuff, right?
Oh, yes.
Yet?
I have good dreams.
(audience laughs and cheers)
Alright.
I didn't even know that
was allowed, I wasn't sure.
Oh no, that's allowed.
You can have good dreams?
Thank God, we can have
good dreams, yes, yes.
All right, okay.
All right.
You've got a healthy outlook Father.
So you just threw a bunch
of canned tomato goop
into this frying pan.
And we're going to crush them.
Next we're going
So far a monkey
could have done all this.
When does it get really complicated?
Well, it's not really complicated
that's why I don't write
complicated cook books.
Good, good
I don't believe in that.
Five table spoons of olive oil.
Okay.
All right.
Speed it up, we're on TV.
I'm doing as fast as I can.
Okay.
(audience laughs)
Next, we're going to crush the garlic.
Okay.
Now, in your cookbook you have
many kind of saucy dishes,
so to speak, right?
Yes.
There's a lot of stuff in here like,
name some of the others will you.
Well, there's another dish
that they make in Northern Italy
which is called (speaks Italian)
which is supposed to do the
same thing for the northerners.
Really?
Yes.
Okay.
The southerners don't need it that much.
Southerners,
they don't have any problem
No problem whatsoever.
Okay, all right.
What is it in this stuff
that actually makes,
the man excited?
Garlic
Garlic!
Garlic helps your love life, all right.
As long as you both eat.
Okay.
Yes
All right
(audience laughs)
We add the garlic.
And then we're going to,
just, the heart of the silk.
Now you'll notice that we
did not saute anything.
No, we did saute anything.
Exactly.
All right.
And we're going to put the heart,
of the silk in there
and that's going to cook
Should I be stirring this?
Yes please.
Just give me something to do.
Please yes.
I feel like ridges okay.
(audience laughs and cheers)
West Catholic
And he's my Catholic
(audience sad)
What does that even mean?
I don't know.
Can you just give that pasta a little stir
so it doesn't
Can I use the same thing
right here
Absolutely, sure
Who cares?
We're not really gonna eat it.
No
(audience laughs)
Not this one.
Our talk show food
gets thrown out of the window after this.
All right.
The next thing we do, is we get carrots
and we cut half the carrots.
Okay
All right
Is this low in cholestrol
because I have sky high cholestrol?
Yes, very, very low.
Guess how high my cholestrol is?
How?
Pushing 300.
Yeah!
(audience laughs)
I have almost 300 cholestrol.
I could go at anytime
Please, don't do it now,
I didn't bring my holy oil with me.
(audience laughs)
You can't cook with holy oil.
Yes you can, it's olive oil.
You can?
Yes, it's olive oil.
You can actually cook with blessed oil?
Yes you can.
That's great.
Yeah for emergency.
All right
(Conan laughs)
Emergency!
He's dying, quick we have to make pasta
(audience laughs)
What kind of an emergency is that?
(audience laughs and cheers)
I don't quite understand.
Let me just say one
thing, about this dish,
I've very good friend
and I think you know him,
Dom de Louise.
Yes, well I've never met Dom de Louise
but I've seen all the
Cannonball Run movies.
(audience laughs)
Okay.
Dom says, that pasta is like sex.
When it's good, it's really good.
When it's bad, it's not that bad.
(audience laughs)
Oh Father!
Father, please!
All right, you know, we're
actually completely out of time
can when we finish this up right now?
Yes, I'm gonna finish it up right now
and I'm gonna show you what
the final dish looks like.
Here we go.
My mami! it went all over the floor.
Yeah, we don't have a real sink,
so there's a lot hot water
spilling back here right now.
We have this crappy talk show sink.
It's just hot water everywhere.
(audience cheers)
That's very good.
This is very good.
Here, have some.
No no no.
It's lent and you know
You gave this up for lent
Yes
You should do what I do, give up cigars,
I don't smoke them anyway.
Interesting thing in the world to do.
All right, we're gonna run.
Father Orsini, thank
you very much being here
(audience cheers)
We'll be right back